hey everybody happy new year so 2016 s
come to a close so it's time to talk
about all the dead characters on Game of
Thrones
that we want back so this is going to be
my top ten list and I know you're all
wondering about when the next trailer is
going to come so I'll try to include
some of that at the end of this to just
careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on the show so far and
there is a new round of the game of
Thrones giveaway they just released
enhanced editions of the book so it's
basically for the value of those
enhanced editions all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video be sure to click
that Bell to enable alerts so you don't
miss anything so a lot of time
characters are killed off in big twists
moments to shock the audience to remind
you that no one is safe anybody can be
killed sometimes they're killed off
because the writers write themselves
into a corner and they can't think of
anywhere else to take the character in
sometimes they're killed off because
they're overpowered or they have too
much knowledge and they become a crutch
for other characters to lean on that the
writers don't want the other characters
to have so Barristan Selmy for instance
was a crutch for Daenerys to lean on he
had so much experience so much knowledge
he knew all about Rhaegar Targaryen
somebody who we need a lot more
information about so naturally the
writers took him away so let's go
through this list and I'll explain for
the characters on the show that are dead
but are still alive in the books why it
is I think that they killed them on the
show the quote from george RR martin
says it all 2016 was directed by me i'm
sorry so so many people we've lost so
let's remember some of the really cool
ones
number 10 Duran Martel an amazing book
character but was probably killed off on
the show because the writers wrote
themselves into a corner with the door
and storyline it's a really big
storyline in the books but on the TV
show they don't have that much time to
focus on it so it seems like they were
just stepping around it because they
wanted to use a couple of the sand snake
characters but they had all this stuff
that was happening down south and they
needed to find a way to not have to go
back there on a regular basis to explain
what was going on so naturally if the
sand snakes were on the loose he would
have sent an army after them to stop
them from causing more chaos so what do
you do you have to kill him so it
totally sucks
this also had
the unintended consequence of making the
door--and storyline even more hated than
it already was so even though Game of
Thrones is an amazing show not all the
storylines shine like Lannister gold
every once in a while they run into
problems just like any other TV show so
may you rest in peace
Dornish master plan in the books the
idea of the Dornish master plan is that
Duran was secretly working as part of
this conspiracy to put a Targaryen back
on the throne and was arranging to have
one of his children
Quentin marry Daenerys to form an
alliance but like the TV show changing
things from the books Quentin was
excised from the story trystane was
murdered by the sand snakes trying to
end the Martell regime it seems like
there aren't any Martel's left so who
has power now the sand snakes is their
open revolt in the streets we have no
idea number 9
Shireen Baratheon this is one of the
saddest deaths on the show but it proved
great fuel for sir Davos to go after
Melisandre so she's still alive in the
books but it sounds like she might meet
the same fate the reason that Dan and
Dave said that they killed her off on
the show in the way that they did like
having Stannis execute her as an
offering to the red God to ensure their
victory which did really come at least
not the way they expected it against the
forces of the Bolton's is because they
felt like Stannis had crossed the line
and was committed to his cause he was so
stubborn that he was not going to waver
so when Melisandre put it to him we need
royal blood he offered up Shireen the
reason I think they couldn't use his
wife Solis is because her blood did not
flow from Stannis's that was the whole
idea the King's blood flowed through
shereen's veins because it came from
Stannis so it was mostly a death that
was borne out of the logic of Stannis's
course on the TV show in provided like a
really big shocking moment in sort of
the first ice block in the giant wall
that was Melisandre misinterpreting
visions in her perceived downfall she's
down but not out we'll have to talk
about Melisandre stuff in another video
because she was still effective in
bringing Jon Snow back from the dead so
she does have power but she
misinterprets her visions so sadly led
- Sherine being sacrificed number eight
Barristan Selmy another really terrible
death he's an amazing character that's
still alive in the books he's supposed
to have his own POV chapter during winds
of winter the problem is is that he was
this huge crutch for Daenerys like I
said so the writers wanted a big
shocking moment they wanted her to feel
alone so they took that away so that was
sort of paving the way for her new small
Council
with Tyrion to come in so we're starting
to see this thing where you know
Daenerys has three dragons she has this
very good advisor Tyrion but slowly and
slowly she's gotten more and more
powerful so the writers have started to
take stuff away from her that might
continue into Season seven if she seems
invincible there's no way that's gonna
last so whatever her crutches her
dragons her advisors those will slowly
go away over the course of the next two
seasons it would really suck if my 2017
characters that we want back list
included a dragon on it but number seven
the blackfish went out like a champ I
know a lot of people were like hey we
didn't see a body he's not dead the idea
was is that he was going to fight off
the Lannister army till he was killed
Jamie didn't really have much use for
the blackfish because ed Muir controlled
the castle and he had capitulated so the
Lannisters were already in control so
this is another one of those Stannis
type death moments where they imply that
he's going to be killed but they don't
just outright show it to you so you just
left a wonder I think the blackfish is
dead I think that was the whole idea of
that last scene with Brienne so may you
rest in peace blackfish you SAS like a
champ he was one of the funniest most
Monty Python things about the season so
number six mance rayder we have not seen
him in a while but he is so much cooler
in the books he becomes a much bigger
part of them trying to retake Winterfell
from the Bolton's he infiltrates it
using glamour so the only thing the show
has done with glamour thus far is just
show us Melisandre Jewel just show us
like the 200 year old lady that she
really is even though she's been using
that Jewel to stay young that's part of
the glamour process like you have to
have that next to your skin in order for
it to work but the show probably killed
mance off because it wasn't going to
doing a lot of his storyline there were
just a lot of characters involved in
that northern plot that they were going
to do on the show so there wasn't much
reason to keep him around they didn't
want him to be as grand of a figure they
wanted the conflict between the
Brotherhood in the wildlings to devolve
into Jon Snow's death so if mance were
still around then that probably wouldn't
have happened like he probably would
have helped keep things under control so
number five maester aemon a Targaryen
alone in the world is a terrible thing
so he was another one of those
characters there was a crutch for Jon
Snow to lean on he's on his path to
becoming a leader in his own right
so naturally like Daenerys lost
Barristan Selmy Jon Snow lost maester
aemon may he rest in peace the actor
playing him also passed away after they
had filmed most of his scenes so it was
very sad but he lived a very long life
maester aemon even in the context of
this show had lived an extremely long
life he has this really interesting
backstory that I'll do in another video
sometime soon but his brother was egg
from the duncan egg series who ascended
the iron throne
because maester aemon was in line ahead
of him but chose to abdicate because he
didn't want to create another Targaryen
Civil War where all of his brothers
would end up dying so he took the black
went to the wall became a maester that
is kind of fun to think about what would
that have looked like maester aemon
sitting on the Iron Throne number 4
Stannis Baratheon a lot of people were
really upset when the show killed him
off he's still alive in the books
they're getting ready for sort of their
episode 9 Battle of the bastards type
episode but in the books I'm referring
to it as the Battle of Winterfell
Stannis is getting ready for that but
ultimately I think you know because he's
not destined to sit on the Iron Throne
he will be killed off eventually so the
show was just making a beeline for that
Stannis as Melisandre believed it was
not the prince who was promised that is
someone else she starts to believe in
Jon Snow then he comes back and now it
seems like that's him he's the one
that's destined to rise up so the
question now remains how a SAN is going
to die in the books is it going to
happen in a similar way will he fall he
was one of the best characters on the
show even though he was an [ __ ] till
the day he died
he was just so much fun but number three
is Catelyn Stark for obvious reasons for
ladies stone heart reasons so it'd be
amazing to have that character on the
show but I think you know because they
didn't want too many people coming back
from the dead to spoil the Jon Snow
reveal they just decided to cut her out
of the show she also takes control of
the Brotherhood in the Riverlands it
becomes this big storyline the TV show
wanted the Brotherhood to head north
they want to bring in storyline to take
place with Sansa
so the writer said behind the scenes she
was never in any conversations to ever
come on the show so it wasn't like they
were almost gonna do her and then
decided not to they just immediately
decided that when Catelyn Stark died
that was it she wasn't coming back
so she's a really awesome character in
the books we can totally talk more about
her when the next book comes out see
where her storyline goes but number two
is Ned Stark we kind of did get him back
but not in the way we expected he's one
of the few characters on the show and in
the books that's in on one of the best
well-kept secrets in the kingdom who are
Jon Snow's parents what does that mean
for the story would it throw the kingdom
into chaos so of course the character
that knows everything dies off and now
it seems like bran is the path to them
learning about that so they haven't
confirmed whether or not the actor that
plays young Ned Stark is going to be
coming back for Season seven he could
totally come back it just depends on how
they're going to treat more flashbacks
on the TV show and which characters they
would need for that because there are a
couple key characters including my
number one Rhaegar Targaryen the one
person that we've heard a lot about but
have not seen yet so there have been
numerous storylines that have called him
out
Daenerys learned about him through
Barristan Selmy we learn a little bit
about him through Robert Baratheon
storyline in the early seasons of the
show
and then now even though the show's only
implied it you know behind the scenes
HBO sort of unofficially confirmed
Rhaegar Targaryen is Jon Snow's father
so it just blows your mind and blows the
story wide open because you start to see
Ned Stark's motivation for keeping it
secret for so long so he's just a
character who is dead now that we really
want back so that we can see some of
this play out because it's some of the
best drama ever in it's something that
fans have been waiting for since
nineteen
96 when the first book was published
that's where Ned Stark has the dreams
where he dreams about the Tower of joy
you get the first glimpse of what this
scene is right here the scene that brand
flashes back to so that's how long
people have waited to get more
information about Lyanna Stark Rhaegar
Targaryen and Jon Snow so let me know in
the comments who are the dead characters
that you really want back on the TV show
it doesn't even have to make sense but
you know most of the characters that are
alive in the books that are dead on the
TV show were killed off for a roundabout
reasons but like George RR Martin's says
you know 2016 directed by him I'm sorry
there's a lot of death in Game of
Thrones so a lot of that's just to show
you the casual nature of death in that
world nobody is safe anybody can be
killed off it doesn't matter how special
you think you are just remind you of
your own mortality so if there any bonus
videos that you guys want me to do for
say like maester aemon the Targaryen or
anything from Game of Thrones history
just let me know in the comments so say
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner the Promethean you win a $20
Amazon gift card please private message
me on the back end of my channel so we
can get your contact details so there's
a whole bunch more stuff coming in the
next couple of days we got some teasers
for season six around this time last
year I'm not expecting a season 7 teaser
for at least a little while longer maybe
when we get closer to the Superbowl but
typically Game of Thrones doesn't
advertise on the Superbowl but they
might choose that time to release
something out into the wild just like
hey remember this is the show please
don't forget about us so there might be
some new footage coming soon but I'm not
expecting an official trailer for a
little while well you guys wait for my
next video to post you can click here to
learn all about Aegon the conquerors
history and you can click here to learn
all about Deadpool in the Wolverine
movie thank you so much for watching
happy New Year everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you